the worst war that you've never heard of
happened in Bosnia and there's this one
moment that really has stuck with me as
we've been reporting on it it's the
1990s and there's a full-blown ethnic
cleansing happening Serbian soldiers are
Marching across Bosnia kicking people
out of their homes burning their
Villages and doing terrible things the
UN and the International Community knew
this was happening and they really
didn't do much to stop it and the
question is why don't we have the UN for
this very reason yes but we have to
remember that the UN isn't some like
special country the UN is just made up
of all the other countries and all the
other countries have interests and
values and priorities and so the UN is
only as strong as its member nations and
at the time the Soviet Union had just
Fallen there was a lot going on in the
international stage un countries weren't
really interested in sending their
people into this conflict this led to
the world standing by with the power to
stop horrible things from happening and
not doing anything it's a really
powerful lesson for us as we look to
other conflicts around the world today